[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mme amhis à faire bouger pour tarbes ou
sans pression ni relâche
partager ma passion cela comme des dix
nouvelles maximum sur cette piste alors
que sandra bouchard et façon
ce parti
soit le magnat place
bienvenue
c'est ça que je
je veux
ça
c'est bête alors que des voix
je tout le monde tous ces faits ce débat
fa
[Musique]
oui
tout ce que tu ouvres
à
[Musique]
oh ouais
je klum en plus
pas vous
m
[Musique]
oui maintenant pour ça
moussu
[Musique]
ok
besson
depuis sept jours
son show
où sont vos différents clubs
[Musique]
oh
je vous supplie le combler
[Musique]
oui maintenant touchés
oh
sur ce son choix
où je crois à l'est pour aller manger
ça
[Musique]
ce soit
ah ah
[Musique]
oui maintenant
non
pour
[Musique]
en effet la très bas qui sont avait tout
jeune équipe de vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]